familiar faces and new ones french mps
arrived at the national assembly after
parliamentary elections on sunday that
dealt a humiliating blow to the french
president his centrist alliance failed
to secure a majority after big gains by
the far-right party and a new left-wing
alliance that is now france's main
opposition force
the success of the left was that we were
able to unite to offer an alternative to
macron's socially and fair policy
in her constituency in northern france
far-right leader marine le pen was in a
buoyant mood after her anti-immigration
party won a record number of seats
will emanuel macron be able to do what
he wants now no the answer is no
no is a word that mps from mackerel's
alliance are likely to hear a lot in
coming weeks as they try to work with
other parties to push through the
president's reformist agenda no we will
not have a contract a governmental
contract between our two parties
that's not something we're going to do
this analyst says that macros mps may
have to work bill by bill another option
is try uh and seek an alliance for each
law and each reform you will pass so
either an alliance with the left when it
is a text more inclined towards the left
or with the right the results of the
parliamentary election have shaken a
political system where power sharing is
rare this newspaper says that the
results are a slap in the face for
emmanuel macron whilst this one says
that france is now going to be
ungovernable
france's government spokeswoman put on a
brave face and said the party will find
a way
it will be difficult we'll of course
need imagination audacity and openness
macros meeting party members and allies
to consider what to do next as a
president who prides himself on his
ability to navigate through a crisis he
finds himself in the middle of one he'd
rather have avoided and that will shape
his second term
natasha butler al jazeera paris